despite two recent tense phone
conversations between u.s president joe
biden and russia's leader vladimir putin
russian troops remain near the border
with ukraine this week the u.s backed by
its allies will demand the kremlin stand
down there will be a massive
consequences for russia if it renews its
aggression uh by which i mean uh
economic financial uh and other
consequences that includes cutting off
russian banks from global transactions
but whether putin is ready to negotiate
or finish the job he started in 2014
with the seizure of ukraine's crimean
peninsula remains a question the kremlin
wants ukraine barred from nato the white
house says that's non-negotiable but
remains hopeful our approach to
discussions will be pragmatic results
oriented and we believe there are areas
we can make progress on
three meetings are scheduled but already
russia's foreign minister is saying
talks could break down after the first
negotiators from nato and russia are
scheduled to sit down wednesday we need
to be prepared
for
that
the talks breaks down and that
diplomacy will fail
and that's exactly why
we are
[Music]
sending a very clear message to russia
that if they once again decide to use
military force against
a neighbor then there will be severe
consequences
the u.s has said it's open to discussing
limits on missile deployments and troop
exercises in europe but no troop
reductions
but fearing a war the pentagon has
already sent a portion of 60 million
dollars worth of military equipment to
ukraine ahead of these talks it's
another signal to putin that it won't
just be ukraine's army to fight should
russian troops invade
jennifer johnson global news washington